[Music]
[Applause]
i think the deathstroke uh slade wilson
is a character you really should never
root for he's definitely a villain you
know i think there's times where people
try to play him as a hero or as
anti-hero but to me he's always been a
villain and like one of the best
villains that dc has
and you know he's an enemy of the teen
titans and i think he's an enemy of
literally legacy for the dcu
and i've always enjoyed writing villains
and i thought there was something to him
that was kind of interesting like you
kind of look at what christopher priest
did in the last run when he was able to
play around with all these ideas of who
deathstroke is
and i think the idea of somebody like
slave wilson suddenly realizing one day
like i'm a bad person
i think there's something interesting to
that of like what does that person do
next
[Music]
so slate at the beginning of the story
is very much struggling with who he is
and what his role moving forward is he
doesn't believe that he is deserving of
his family to be around them but he also
doesn't really know
what the next steps he's going to take
are he's a little lost
and so when the secret organization
called trust comes to him and they say
like hey we're going to
basically give you money we're going to
pay you to save the world and so they're
coming to him with this he's like all
right i understand i understand money so
i'm going to follow this but in the
process of that the process of working
with trust and trying to go like save
the world with them it forces him to
confront certain parts of himself and
again like it really takes him on
this kind of dark journey and it really
makes him deal with the fact that like
he's not a hero regardless of what he
wants to do that that is a fantasy and
it's never going to happen
and so for him to sort of come to the
conclusion that i'm villain
he also realizes well if i'm gonna be a
villain i'm gonna be the best villain
black canary is like one of my favorite
characters in the dcu i've wanted to
write them for a long time they were
almost in robin at one point and so we
kept talking about what we wanted to do
with her and so when this book came up
and i needed someone to essentially be
investigating trust and we started
talking about birth to prey and oracle
and i was you know i think oracle
would totally send black carry on this
mission and so she also she plays a
balance like a counter balance a
contrast with deathstroke right like
that's what's bad she is good she's able
to tolerate working with destro because
that's what the mission calls for like
she doesn't like him you know they have
a long history together they were on
team seven together there were missions
over to pray together but they've
they've fought against each other when
she was in the justice league and
they've had other encounters over the
last few years particularly they they do
not get along
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been a really big fan of howard
porter's ever since he worked on the ray
with christopher priest and he was
underwear on legion mark wade and then
he was on jla with grant morrison which
is like one of the best justice league
books of all time and i've always wanted
to work with him i was like well like
howard why don't we try and do something
together that is just really big fun
action bombastic like really over the
top like muscle cars
you know very much this like
action book with a lot of explosions in
it and howard dived at it i think it's
some of the best work powers i've done
they go up against this new version of
the hive and i got howard got to play
around with some really creepy weird
horror stuff we have this horrific
moment where we see one of the villains
and it's the hive king
and he has a high for a head and it's
just super creepy and weird and i saw
that and i was like oh my gosh like
howard just really nailed it and it all
looks amazing i think it's some of the
best work howard has done in years
in issue one we reveal that deathstroke
has access to all this fat tech now and
one of the things when we started
talking about the opening was i was like
oh that's going to make this like
dramatic opening and either it could be
with a
motorcycle or a helicopter maybe he like
you know dives in you know like skydives
in and i was like no you know he has
batman attack he should totally drive
the batmobile in because the idea of
destroy grabbing the batmobile is so
sacrilegious to me and i know that if
batman was out like knew this was
happening he'd be so pissed off and it
felt so in character with deathstroke
to know like
that him driving the batmobile
would piss off batman it just made it
like extra fun and that was part of my
thinking in the beginning sequence
[Music]
you